okay I've got a new story for you that
sounds like an old story but it's not
it's just that it happened yet again we
have new all-time hottest temperature
records that were set all over the
northern hemisphere over the last week
climate scientists are reporting that
the heat that we've had over the last
week I experienced it in New York City
when I was there for a wedding I told
you about that a few days ago this is
part of many northern hemisphere all
time high temperatures for this time in
the year it's not just the United States
in the u.s. we had all sorts of highs
Denver hit an all-time high on June 28th
for June 28th but it also includes Oman
it includes Northern Ireland it includes
Georgia the Republic of Georgia not the
state the US state of Georgia Armenia
all over the world record high maximum
temperatures and record high minimum
daily temperatures Quebec has had deaths
linked to the heatwave the UK has had
the warmest June since records started
being kept more than a hundred years ago
northern Siberia has been setting
temperature records and the climate
deniers actually you know I don't even
know that I should call them climate
sceptics anymore I was gonna say deniers
or skeptics if they're really just
deniers they will say this is cyclical
it's too short a period of time to
notice real trends a hundred years 200
years of temperature data that's not
really anything and of course it ignores
a ton of other data right it ignores
that climate change models as Joe
McConnell told us earlier on the show
predict exactly this not just rising
temperatures overall but erratic high
and low temperatures and it's not just
temperature because we are also able to
figure out the amount of co2 in the
atmosphere we can track sea level rise
we can track all sorts of different data
and this is why trump is extra dangerous
right now because we can fix some of his
misdeeds like I said earlier we need on
this issue a president who wants to
double down on science and double down
on engineering and climatology not
someone who wants to get us out of the
Paris climate deal and double down on
conspiracy theories and
self-aggrandizement and I want to remind
you I think we should remind ourselves
with this tweet every time we talk about
this issue Trump tweeted once quote the
concept of global warming was created by
and for the Chinese in order to make
American manufacturing non-competitive
this matters one thing to revive the
coal industry when this is going on
matters and I wonder how much longer
will I be reporting to you even more
record high temperatures and record low
temperatures and melting land ice
how much longer will I and many others
be reporting this stuff until we
actually take action because it's been
years and years and the window to act is
getting smaller and smaller and I spoke
to somebody over the weekend it was
actually kind of depressing Pat he was
saying to me you know I I am an
environmentalist I really care about
this but he's thinking of changing his
mentality altogether to just forget
about the environmentalism and the
activism because he's realizing we are
doing irreversible damage and either
we're gonna find a way to live on other
planets once we destroy this one or were
not and I can't do anything about it
this was the realization this person
came to it was incredibly fatalistic and
depressing but in some way look at
what's going on we we need to be acting
now and we are not yeah a lot of the
stuff we can't reverse I mean I guess if
you want to remain a little bit
optimistic there are things like solar
geoengineering we could look into or
maybe even terraforming another planet I
don't know but I don't want to be too
fatalist about it but if the plan is we
have to terraform planets which would
take a very very long time is it really
going to make a difference if you want
to drive the SUV do you just drive the
SUV because no matter what we're
destroying it I'm not advocating for
this view I'm telling you what someone I
spoke to over the weekend at an
extraordinarily warm outdoor event by
the way was telling me and I don't
that's not how I view issues but he
started to make some sense not in terms
of what I would like but in terms of the
pragmatic realities write to me and tell
me why I'm wrong
can we still undo the damage that we're
doing I am thrilled to tell you that
today's episode is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman blinka is a
really unique service for your phone
tablet and web browser and
it is incredibly useful for people like
me who love books and learning but are
busy blinka stakes the best and most
popular non-fiction books and condenses
them into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure
that if you're like me you have a very
long list of books that you've been
meaning to read you only have so many
hours in the day and that's why blink
astiz so amazing they take the most
important information the themes the
insights from each book and they distill
it into a 15 minute audio book that you
can listen to in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blankets
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube
i've put a link in the description i
have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli
nki st.com /p a que ma n